This is Parker Ranch.
With 130,000 sprawling green acres and over
10,000 cows, it’s one of America’s
oldest and largest cattle ranches.
But it’s not located in
Montana, Nebraska, or Texas.
Instead, it’s nestled on the world's most
isolated populous archipelago… Hawaii.
Despite this seclusion, Parker Ranch
has one huge advantage: it’s American.
These beach-going bovines are exempt from tariffs,
import quotas, and foreign health certifications.
The company has direct, domestic access to
the world’s number one consumer of beef.
The country that comprises just 4% of the
global population but eats 21% of its cows.
At least, this should be an advantage.
The United States should benefit from this
convergence of domestic supply and demand.
…One far from unique to beef.
Take, for instance, oil.
Americans may be its most notoriously gluttonous
consumers, but forget the Middle East — the
U.S. produces nearly as much as it uses — 18
versus 19 million barrels a day, respectively.
To a remarkable extent, America has what it needs.
For this, it has not only its size to thank,
but also its unmatched economic
and geographic diversity.
From the cold, continental Northeast to the hot,
bone-dry Southwest, it spans
the whole climatic spectrum.
Now throw in Honolulu and Fairbanks,
and America truly has everything.
In addition to being blessed with many
of the precise inputs it requires,
it’s also lucky enough to have 95,000 miles
of coastline with which to connect them.
Though we may take it for granted, the result
is the best of both worlds — a massive,
diverse, and well-endowed landmass,
yet, because of its abundant waterways,
the kind of cheap, efficient transport
usually reserved for much denser places.
Strangely, you won’t find as much evidence of
this good fortune as its geography would suggest.
For a country capable of being so self-sufficient,
it sources a surprisingly small
share of its trade internally.
Despite, for example, its almost perfect
symmetry of oil production and consumption,
nearly 50% is shipped away overseas, and
the same amount imported from abroad.
Pig farmers in North Carolina buy their
soybeans not from Iowa but Brazil.
And Maryland, its rock salt not from Louisiana
— a thousand miles away — but Chile — over five.
Of course, there are many reasons to ship the
same product from further away — some obvious
and some not. Global trade is an intricate web
of nested decisions and fluctuating trade-offs.
But unlike, say, foreign subsidies, which
no doubt diminish American competitiveness,
one reason is entirely self-inflicted.
The first clue that something strange is
happening — something beyond the normal,
inscrutable quirks of
shipping — lies in this graph.
The United States ships about 50% more
cargo by rail today than in 1960. We
have more oil pipelines, more trucks, and
far more international shipping lanes.
In fact, every major type of transportation
has seen growth in the last half-century. How
could they not when the population
doubled? Except, curiously, one.
American ships move less cargo domestically
today than they did 60 years ago,
when a gallon of gas cost 31 cents and the first
episode of “The Flintstones” aired on television.
This is clearly not the inevitable
outcome of market forces.
This is the result of an arbitrary, inefficient,
outdated, and unnecessary
impediment to the U.S. economy.
One reason America fails to take full advantage of
its fantastic geography is a single clause
in a 103-year-old law called the Jones Act.
It states that any ship moving goods
between two American ports must be…
ONE — Built in the United States,
TWO — Crewed by U.S. Citizens,
THREE — Owned by U.S. Citizens,
and FOUR — Registered in the U.S.
Foreign ships can still, for example, bring
goods from Hong Kong to Seattle — in fact,
they do this every day. They can even then
proceed to Los Angeles before returning to Asia.
What they can’t do is pick anything
up in Seattle and bring it to LA.
Once something arrives on America’s shores,
it can legally no longer be touched by the
very same foreign boat that brought it.
Many countries have laws of this variety.
But none are nearly as strict as America,
which had to negotiate for itself a special
exception to free trade rules when joining the
World Trade Organization. Not a great look for
the self-described champion of “open markets.”
The reason any of this matters is that,
as will surprise exactly no one,
American labor is not cheap.
American ships are therefore more
expensive to build, operate, and maintain.
Now, you might be thinking “Of course! American
architects are also more expensive. So are its
nurses and teachers.” That boats are
too may not sound all that scandalous.
And, normally, you’d be right.
But hundred-million-dollar boats are not ‘normal’
products. They’re the textbook
example of economies of scale.
Building a hundred ships, in other words,
is astronomically cheaper —
per unit — than building fifty.
Still, it would be one thing if we were
talking about fifty. Or even 25. But once you
get down to the single digits, the cost per ship
skyrockets to the point of being almost comical.
What would it cost to build just two F-35s?
That’s about how many oceangoing, cargo-carrying
ships America builds in a typical year.
American ships cost more, so fewer are built,
and because fewer are built, they cost more.
You can watch this feedback cycle play
out over the last century. In 1920,
American-built ships were 20% more expensive.
That rose to 50% by the 30s, 200% by the
50s, 300% by the 90s, and 500% today.
That, mind you, is before a boat even
christened. Once it sees the light of day,
operating costs are 2.7 times higher,
according to the U.S. Maritime Administration.
Another source found a difference of six.
American ships aren’t just more
expensive. They’re not just way
more expensive. They're so expensive that
they exist in an entirely separate category.
Truly. Because U.S. ships cost five times more
than their foreign counterparts, they simply can’t
compete. Therefore, unless subsidized, they’re
approximately never used for foreign trade.
There’s the American fleet and
there’s the rest of the world.
Shipping anything domestically
by water is a very last resort.
You’d sooner hire a donkey to carry your cargo
overland from Seattle to Boston than use a boat.
Of course, the Jones Act only applies to boats.
U.S. airlines can buy from
Airbus and truckers from Volvo.
You can probably see where this is going.
Since the Jones Act was passed in 1920, America
has seen an unmistakable shift from maritime to
every other form of transport, as
we saw in this graph from earlier.
The Jones Act is by no means the
only reason — the U.S. also built
an entire interstate highway system in the
interim — but there’s no doubt in its role.
Today, just 2% of American freight
travels by sea. In Europe, where,
by the way, there are also
highways — that number is 40%.
Even Hawaiian cows have opted for air travel.
Live calves are driven from the serene northern
tip of the Big Island to Kona International
Airport and flown on 747s to California.
In the end, Americans collectively pay for every
pound of cargo diverted from ship to airplane,
truck, or train in the form of
traffic jams and carbon emissions.
No mode of transport generates fewer
greenhouse gas emissions than boat.
And while a cargo ship may be slower than
a truck, it’s far more cost-effective.
Rivers and oceans are relatively green,
maintenance-free, infinite-lane highways.
We also pay in the form of lost revenue.
However close an American supplier and
however far its foreign competitor,
the latter is almost always cheaper
when ocean transport is required.
To use a highly imperfect analogy,
the Jones Act is a bit like congress
mandating that the left half of
every road suddenly be abandoned.
Not to make room for some urbanist utopia — this
is still the United States of
America we’re talking about.
Our four million miles of asphalt
wouldn’t be converted into bicycle
or pedestrian paths — they would
just sit there, taking up space.
At first, given the lack of
public transit alternatives,
the loss of half our roads would
slow down everyone’s commute.
But over time, knowing America’s
addiction to cars, we’d extend
our freeways to compensate for the lost left half.
Strange and arbitrary though this rule,
transportation wouldn’t grind to a halt
forever — we’d adapt — but at an enormous
environmental, social, and financial cost.
The Jones Act hasn’t doomed America to
financial ruin. For most of the country,
it’s merely diverted cargo to less
efficient, more damaging modes of transport.
But some places don’t have this luxury.
There are no roads or trains
connecting Hawaii, Puerto Rico,
or Guam to the mainland.
These are captive markets.
Unable to extend their highways
in the previous analogy,
these places are stuck with what they’ve got.
Hawaii, Puerto Rico, and Alaska collectively
make up just 1.6% of the U.S. population, but shi
p 35% of all domestic ocean-going
tonnage. They have to.
And what happens in captive markets with little
or no competition? Price gouging and price fixing.
Two companies — TOTE and Crowley control more than
80% of the U.S. mainland to Puerto Rico market.
Alaska is subject to a TOTE and Matson duopoly.
And Hawaii and Guam are no different.
It should be no surprise, therefore,
that, in 2011, two Jones Act carriers
pled guilty to criminal price-fixing.
Now, lobbyists are quick to point
out that we really have no idea
how much this law hinders the U.S. economy.
And they’re right. The sheer complexity
of global shipping makes it nearly
impossible to honestly and accurately
disentangle the effects of a single law.
Anyone claiming to have such an
estimate that fully accounts for
U.S. labor and tax laws — which would
likely still apply if the Jones Act
were repealed — is either delusional
or openly admits to much uncertainty.
But whether the total cost is $64 billion, as
the OECD estimates, or even just 10% of that,
don’t mistake our inability to precisely
quantify the cost with the lack of a cost.
After all, there’s plenty of evidence.
Take a look, for instance,
at where Puerto Rico gets its natural
gas compared to the Dominican Republic.
Despite being just 130 miles
apart, the difference is stark.
Puerto Rico, a U.S. territory, gets 0% of its
LNG from the U.S., while its neighbor gets 65%.
Because of the Jones Act, Puerto
Ricans effectively pay more for
American products than do foreign countries.
So, while the lower 48 have largely
abandoned domestic shipping entirely,
these distant territories have been forced into a
battle with their own government
to find and exploit loopholes.
In fact, the Jones Act itself was a
defensive attack against earlier workarounds.
Before its passage in 1920, someone in Seattle
could ship their goods 140 miles by truck
to Vancouver, Canada, then the other 1,600
miles to Anchorage by Canadian-flagged ship.
Alaskans benefitted from this foreign
competition. Unfortunately for them,
they wouldn’t get the right to vote until
Alaska became a state 40 years later.
In the meantime, the Pacific Steamship Company,
based in Washington, which did have a
vote, seized this window of opportunity.
It lobbied Senator Wesley Jones to close the
loophole by inserting a clause
into the Merchant Marine Act.
That clause, now called the “Jones Act”,
specified not only cargo transported “by
water”, but “by water, or by land and water”.
Humorously, it simultaneously opened a
new loophole. The journey from Seattle to
Vancouver could no longer be made by truck,
but it could be made by Canadian train.
Needless to say, things have only gotten
more complex in the past hundred years.
The Jones Act has slowly
transformed into a strange
and arbitrary Swiss-cheese patchwork of rules.
For example, what does it mean for a
public company to be ‘American’ in 2023?
The answer, apparently, is that 75% of
its shareholders must be U.S. citizens.
That is, unless the CEO of the foreign
owner pinkie promises not to interfere
with American interests, in
which case, all is forgiven.
Then, there’s the question of what,
exactly, counts as American-built.
The answer is that the Coast Guard will seize
your ship if it has a foreign-built hull,
but not if it has a foreign-built engine. The
propeller, machinery, consoles, wiring, and piping
can be foreign, but no more than 1.5% of the
steel weight of the superstructure. Make sense?
If not, the U.S. government has prepared
for you a 29-page PDF defining terms
like ‘point’ and ‘transportation’ —
often in strange and unexpected ways.
One of the most important definitions depends on
the precise interpretation of “new and different”.
Recall that you cannot legally
ship your Hawaiian cows on a
foreign ship to Vancouver
and then Seattle by truck.
Except you can… if your product is
manufactured into something, quote,
“new and different” during its foreign pit-stop.
Luckily for Parker Ranch, the U.S.
government considers cows in various
stages of growth as different products.
Calves, versus slaughter cows, for instance.
Parker Ranch could therefore raise its calves
for 30 days until they reached about 400 pounds
and then ship them to Vancouver, where they
were fattened up to 800 or a thousand pounds.
At some unknown point during this process,
they transform, in the eyes of the law,
into “new and different products”, enabling
their shipment down to Sumas, Washington.
But let’s say you’re the world’s most patriotic
Hawaiian cowboy. Even if you’re willing to pay any
price to use American-built ships, you’re going
to run into a new problem: there aren’t any.
…Which gets to the heart of the issue.
Supporters of the Jones Act argue
it does serve a genuine purpose.
That it’s not nearly as arbitrary
as the road analogy would suggest.
This… is true.
The U.S. Military was stretched to
its limits during the First World War.
The Jones Act was intended to prevent this
from happening again — to guarantee a
sizable U.S. fleet in times of need.
And at first glance it appears
to have worked. In total,
there are about 40,000 U.S.-flagged vessels.
But this is highly misleading. The
vast majority of those are barges,
tug boats, and other small ships mainly used
on the Mississippi and other inland rivers.
Barges are great. But they’re far from
ideal replacements for faster, larger,
more reliable, and economical
ocean-going ships like tankers.
They’re also not the kind of ship
the Navy would need during a war.
What it would need are large, ocean-going
ships, of which there are only about 100 left.
That’s right. 100. For the entire United States.
And because American repairs are so
expensive, these 100 ships are old,
outdated, and in some cases, downright dangerous.
One sank in a hurricane in 2015. Since it was 40
years old, it was built without modern lifeboats.
…All of this is to say, there just
aren’t very many American ships.
Typically, cows are transported
by specialized livestock carriers.
But there isn’t a single
one in the whole U.S. of A.
Instead, Hawaiian ranchers had to
invent an entirely new method — what
they call ‘cowtainers’ to get their
cattle on standard cargo ships.
Neither is there a single LNG tanker.
Or asphalt carrier. Or cement carrier.
They just don’t exist.
Now, the most reasonable supporters of
the Jones Act will concede to these costs.
Sure, the situation is less than ideal, they
might say, but “national security” is simply
too important. And while the U.S. fleet is
indeed small, at least it exists at all.
There’s some merit to this
argument. The “free market”
is certainly not some sacred force
of nature we ought never disobey.
What matters is simply whether
the benefits outweigh the costs.
So, is everything we’ve talked about
worth the chance that if America is
involved in a war and if the Navy runs
low and if they’re available and useful,
it can commandeer 100 slow, inefficient,
and outdated commercial ships?
Even if your answer is
‘yes’, a better question is:
If those are indeed our goals, is
there a better way to achieve them?
In fact, the United States already has a
stockpile of militarily-useful ships on reserve.
No, actually, in typical U.S. military fashion,
it has three — the Ready Reserve Force,
Maritime Security Program, and Sealift Command.
Meanwhile, two of the three most prolific
ship-building nations are close, American allies.
We know these countries would sell
the U.S. military the ships it
needs because, well… they do.
Amusingly, most of the Ready Reserve
Force ships were built internationally.
In other words, foreign ships are apparently
good enough for the U.S. military but when it
comes to non-military purely commercial ships,
we’re told to think about “national security”.
In case there was any doubt, this fact
exposes the truth about the Jones Act:
it originated as an opportunistic way
for Senator Wesley Jones to win support
from Washington voters and it continues to
serve that same protectionist purpose today.
A small handful of powerful unions and
their lobbyists have essentially held
America’s incredible geographic potential hostage.
It works because most of us don’t
know or think about the Jones Act.
We never see its costs directly.
It thrives, like many bad
policies, on our lack of awareness.
One of the best ways to increase awareness
is by making videos like this one. That’s
why I made this class on today’s sponsor,
Skillshare, showing you step-by-step how
I make my thumbnails and going behind
the scenes on how I make these videos.
You can also find courses from MKBHD, Thomas
Frank, and many of your other favorite channels.
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of courses
on everything from graphic design, to
project management, and programming.
What’s great about Skillshare is
that you get access to every course
on the platform with a single
subscription. Once you sign up,
you’re motivated to learn more to
make the most of your membership.
An annual subscription costs less than ten bucks a
month and the first 1,000 people to join
by clicking the link on screen now get a
one-month free trial. Thanks again to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video.